I  hey Guardians a new destiny glitch has  been discovered this time it's for the  hunter with the Night Stalker so class  you're now going to be able to shoot  unlimited shadow shot if you have the  right things you quit first and foremost  make sure you have the graviton or fit  exotic helmet secondly make sure you  have the quiver perk selected for your  shadow shot in your sub class once  you've charged up your super go ahead  and take one to two shots and then hit  the auction but give it a second or two  and go back into the game you're going  to realize now that you're super has  been recharged and you can shoot off  another one to two shots and continue to  rinse and repeat enjoy spamming all the  shadow talks now because I'm sure a  hotfix will be coming in soon stay tuned  against live com for your continuing  coverage of destin  you